I know how to set the mood check it out
get it get it get it get it get it get
it girl get it girl take her take her to
the flo show show how you R drop it drop
it drop it l drop itop drop how's it
going bros my name
is welcome to afraid of monsters we need
to hurry the [__] up I'm running out of
barage I need to find apparently they're
in the bathroom and the pipe oh this is
not bathroom you here where's the
bathroom bro bro bathroom quick he zap
oh no where did bathroom
go oh this isn't
good no trust this room I oh God I'm out
of
batteries yep I'm out of B no wait I
still have batteries come on the
B bro oh I'm sorry you're handicapped
bro but I still had to kill you oh
man knife time I'm out of
battery
oh oh man I died I didn't exactly go was
plann all right let's try that one more
time hey where the [__] am
I oh now the background sounds works oh
that's great there's supposed to be a
bathroom where is it here here it is yes
yes yes pick them up
please pick them up yes we're good it's
not going to out and it's
jammed this be conservative with our
ammo this time I don't
oh oh oh oh no no no no no no no no I
don't appreciate you
oh oh oh and caps man
oh [__] I don't trust messes chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
I pressed that what did that do it's an
exit somewhere [__] do I know where it
is is it back to where we chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop and one more hit and I'm dead
go I'm so good I need to
save can't believe I made it this far
holy [__] okay F5 F5 is quick save right
F5 didn't
work I'm not going to no I'm not going
to die here I'm not did it work did it
work no it didn't all right we're safe
hello py hello all
right go o okay yep that's not the right
one where
yes no come here bro come at me bro
don't hit me bro Super Mario hats go
elevator here yes
don't I'm a genius I'm a free can't
believe I me of course I made it this
far I'm on fire
today finally cuz I fail a lot I just
jump down it doesn't look very good can
we open this did I save did I save yeah
I saved two seconds ago oh wow that does
not look good can we go I I don't think
I'm going to die if I go can I cut this
rope chop chop chop chop chop chop can I
open Chop Chop okay let's just jump oh I
can walk here holy [__] oh wait I
couldn't
walk all right uh oh what are you
looking at what are you looking at oh
maybe there's nothing here I yeah there
has to be something here I mean I can
jump here why else would you jump here
oh God don't look at me like that I
would shoot you if I could now how the
[__] do I open this chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop yes I'm
fire okay come at me bro come at me bro
Bruh Bruh come at me bro they're [__]
headless it's like take a shell P Jesus
P all right come back bro come back bro
what am I how am I I have to jump all
right all right oh [__] you have a
friend I don't
appreciate chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop
chop chop ch ch ch ch I got him once ch
ch
chop CH jump chop jump chop
CH chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop I could do this all day
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
oh it's a scientist that's why yeah that
makes sense chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop I don't
care I don't care this game is difficult
as [__] I don't care chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop yes you're dead buddy you're dead I
don't even care anymore how do I get up
here come on bro have to jump okay one
two oh you only wor okay one two chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
no what am I doing here I don't want to
go here chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop oh
let's no chop chop chop I don't like
handicaps I'm
kidding oh no I'm over here again ah
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop I you
stoping the chop chop I can't I can't
chop chop chop chop ow
okayy chop chop chop mattresses no no
chop it's too difficult this game it's
really difficult I mean I I okay maybe
I'm not the best player but damn it's
difficult top CHP top top CHP CHP top
top okay let's save here cuz I bet I'm
going to
die chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop
chop bro come at me bro chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop best commentary
ever oh in
here actually no why did I do that that
didn't help
me ow ow bro no why did you do that
what why maybe here maybe here open yes
go oh girl girl came at me and she was
like no
no wait where are
me oh oh no I'm stuck here okay no more
freaky girls
please oh this is trash remember blue
light to Blue Door there's no way I can
remember that all
[Music]
right it's like oh yeah a door is open
but I have no clue where that [__]
door
is uh all right we got durel and uh B
then anyway chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop CH I'm such a good
commentator chop chop chop chop chop
chop CHP top go Blue Door where's the
blue door oh this is blue go where's the
blue door where's the blue door CHP top
CHP top to top CH top Blue Door Blue
Door Blue Door Blue Door ah the
handicaps ah [__] handicaps all right
Blue Door no this is bathroom
what is this Chop Chop oh it's poo I can
chop poo oh wait I can chop chop chop
chop chop nothing can be Cho that's oh
God look at his handicap chop chop chop
chop ch ch ch ch move away stupid
handicap chop chop chop CH chop chop
chop okay just kidding uh [__]
handicaps bro one more hit and I'm
dead oh this [__] custom story I me
it's not even a [__] custom story
it's a mod right where's the blue door
no no oh I was doing so
good all right do a cell and B it in
come on bro
CHP all right Blue
Door
what can't do [__] Bro Blue Door no
ah backing in something
ah okay I'm screwed I'm screwed for
[Music]
chisle stop
ah it would help if I knew where I was
going they're like remember Blue Door
blue okay but where is the blue door and
it's open so how can I see oh man maybe
upstairs let's try upstairs I mean I
thought there's blue lines on the
there's blue lines on the walls I figure
that I'm so
screwed person it only maybe it's
here oh wait I won just walk in circles
something here ch ch ch ch ch in the
trash Chop Chop toop blue
[Music]
door but it's a blue door sad face all
right
fine missing a lock that sound very Str
ah come I wonder how many times I died
in this [__] play there ch
ch all right I think I can do it this
time probably not but whatever okay here
let's go here and then here
and then here no this is wrong oh God
one more hit and I'm dead maybe it's
here
no all right uh I'm going to end it here
Bros CU I don't know this [__] mod is
too difficult I wish you could change
difficulty uh anyway that's pretty much
it I hope I do better next time I'm
getting better though I'm getting better
though I mean I had a pretty dang
progress I'm just
say
anyway that's pretty
[Music]
it ah somebody thinks of loot should I
really do this I doubt there's anything
to be
honest probably not super important
secret